there was one group of astronomers who
all thought it was around 50 and another
group of astronomers who all thought it
was around 100 and so there was a big
argument running for decades and these
two camps were
you know forever at war with one another
coming up with more and more evidence to
support theirs and to trash the other
camps ideas as to how they should
measure this hubble constant
it's really it's a story that sort of
goes back to the early years of the 20th
century
when astronomers first found out that
all the galaxies or nebulae as they were
known then are all running away from us
um and this caused some consternation
because it looked like there was some
kind of cosmic halitosis that for some
reason all these galaxies were running
away from our own milky way um but
subsequently it was realized that this
was actually down to the expansion of
the entire universe and everything was
running away from us just because the
whole place is getting bigger
and this quantity the hubble constant is
really a measure of how quickly the
universe is getting bigger so the
equation is that v the velocity that the
thing's running away from us is h the
hubble constant times d the distance
away the constant is just a number and
it's unfortunately astronomers measure
in really strange units because really
we usually measure velocities of
galaxies the natural unit to use is
kilometers per second and the distance
to galaxies are typically measured in
megaparsecs millions of parsecs so the
hubble constant has these weird units of
kilometers per second per megapasc and
in those strange units it's a number
that comes out somewhere around 70.
where's it kept is it a number in your
head or is it written down or that i
know that might be stupid that's that's
a really good question because actually
until maybe five ten years ago there
were we didn't actually know what the
value was and in fact bizarrely there
were two schools so i said that the
current value our best estimate is
somewhere around 70 but until five ten
years ago there was one group of
astronomers who all thought it was
around 50 and another group of
astronomers who all thought it was
around 100 and so it was a big argument
running for decades and these two camps
were
you know forever at war with one another
coming up with more and more evidence to
support theirs and to trash the other
camps ideas as to how they should
measure this hubble constant and now
the value is pretty well tied down
there is no kind of official sanction
value that different people use
different values it's just important
when you use it that when you write a
scientific paper you say what value of
the hubble constant you actually used so
that if other people disagree with you
they can always go back and redo the
calculation
the hubble constant
is not really a constant it's a bit of a
misnomer to call it a constant because
actually it's changing with time since
it's a measure of how fast the universe
is expanding because there are various
forces acting on that expansion the pull
of gravity is trying to slow down the
expansion and then more recently we've
discovered this mysterious stuff called
dark energy which is actually making
that expansion speed up with time it
means that this constant has actually
varied over the lifetime of the universe
and so in order to make sure we
understand exactly where we are usually
instead of just calling it h we usually
call it h naught so that's h with a
little zero after it just to say that
that's the particular value of the
hubble constant as it is today it's only
within the last five years we've even
really measured it now today this value
of h naught um and trying to measure the
hubble constant as it was in the past or
how it's going to be in the future is
something that we're really struggling
to do it's probably one of the next
great things in astronomy at least in
cosmology and understanding the large
scale properties of the universe is
really to see how this hubble constants
evolve with time and use that to tell us
about the properties of the universe
whether it's going to be around forever
whether it's going to expand faster and
faster or whether it will ultimately
collapse on itself in a big crunch